she was reveling in pointing out that
she was morally Superior that was one of
the things that was really so gross
about it she came here and and had this
air of superiority and we're better than
you and we're blah blah blah just and it
was just I found it you know you know
what I think the majority report I think
they're like the the incel equivalent of
politics
where like
you get you get a guy who's out of shape
not really not doesn't have good social
skills says crude and rude things smells
bad and has a poor diet and then they
get really jealous that people don't
want to be friends with them so they go
online they get really angry and start
talking about how the world sucks and
how bad it is
and I think that's what the majority
report is because you know you can have
you have this big political space with a
whole bunch of different commentators of
different various backgrounds all having
debates and you know and getting along
to varying degrees and then you have the
majority report where Sam gets like
banned from a bunch of different shows
then complains about it